Asalam alaikum.
I am Ephe. I'm 25 and I'm a sales
manager. As you've said earlier that the
best way of jihad is to taking care of
our parents if they are still alive. Now
the case is that my mom is Christian and
uh I was born in Islam but my mom is
Christian and uh she often asked me to
drop her to the church celebrate
Christmas and do the other Christian
agenda. And on the other side my father
already closed his door for me uh
because I still taking care of my
mother. They were divorced because I
still taking care of my mother. My
father has closed his door for me. He
blocked me. I couldn't reach out him.
And uh what do you think the best
possible way for me to fix my
relationship with them? And uh maybe
other way other possible way for me to
do my jihad. Thank you.
>> Sister uh is your father a Muslim?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. You didn't say that but I
understood. The sister said that father
is a Muslim. Mother is a Christian. She
was born as a Muslim but because of
divorce now parents are staying
separate. The mother she tries to
support the mother. Mother says that she
tells that take me to the church to
celebrate Christmas. I said in my talk
it's mentioned in the Quran that you
have to love and respect your parents.
But also says in surah Lukman chapter 31
verse number 15 and surah Ankabut
chapter 29 verse number 8 that if your
parents do jihad strive and struggle to
make you worship somebody else besides
Allah don't obey them but live with them
in compassion. So if your mother says
that drop me to the church it is not
permitted but when she's coming back
home you can get her back from the
church to the home. Do you understand
there's a difference? Ah okay.
>> Dropping not permitted because you are
helping her to do shik. But when she has
finished if she wants to come back home
you'll be ready outside the church. Get
her home. When she asks you to celebrate
Christmas you ask her why you don't want
to celebrate Christmas. She say oh Jesus
is God. Then you repeat what I said.
>> You do dawa with her.
>> You tell her. You prove to me Jesus is
God. I will accept Christianity.
Correct? So you tell her either you
become a Muslim or I become a Christian.
Correct?
>> Whoever was correct will follow.
Whatever I said in my talk, if you go on
my YouTube, you'll find my talk
similarities with Islam and
Christianity. And I told in the earlier
answer to the sister that if Christian
means following the teachings of Jesus
Christ peace be upon him. We Muslims are
more Christian than the Christian
themselves. Said the same thing. You
should love your mother. Loving a
non-Muslim mother is not wrong.
You have to take care of your mother.
You have to respect your mother. Only
thing those what she says is what is
against the Quran against the teachings
of prophet only those thing don't
follow. If she wears if she says oh
daughter wear blue you may not like blue
in the house. No problem. Blue is not
haram. Wear blue. Make her happy. Give
her gifts. Give her money. No problem.
Love her more. Care for her. Take care
of her. Only those things she says like
celebrating Christmas, dropping to the
church, these things you say mother I'm
not following because this will cause
you damage. I love you but if I come
with you to church even you will go to
hell. I will go to hell. I don't want
you go to hell. I love you my mother. So
you should know how to speak. Do dawa.
This is your jihad. Tell your father
that she's my mother. I have to do
jihad. Do even jihad with your father.
Tell your father it is my duty. Even
though she's a Christian, I have to love
her.
Quran doesn't say that only love your
Muslim mother and father. No, you can't
say to her. But do dawa, convince her.
See my video cassette, give my video
cassels to her, give my books to her,
convince her. Even if she gets angry,
keep on give gifts, give sweets to her.
Correct?
>> How much more you love, more chances she
will accept. and see to it that you
convince her do dawa.
Keep on doing till the last day. That's
your duty. Whether they accept or not,
Allah will not question you if she
doesn't accept. But if you don't do
dawa, Allah will question you. So keep
on doing dawa. Pray to Allah that she
gets haya. I pray to that me she gets
haya. And may may she accept Islam. Hope
that answers the question.